hey everybody welcome back to planet
coaster I wanna take a minute and
explain what this video is all about
because it's called a special occasion
actually recently as you might know
frontier went to the legends of gaming
events in London to show off the game
with the help of the ladies I know and a
bunch of big youtubers and what they
were do is compete against each other in
some parks but of course they would need
some points to compete in and that's
basically where I got asked to make a
park and that's what this one is made
for and you are pretty much looking at
the results of a couple of hours of
making that Park right now now the
reason that I'm releasing it at this
point is that it was supposed to be a
secret until legends of gaming is over
which it is now and I recorded some of
the parts of making this Park not all of
it it still took quite a few more hours
to make it but hopefully this video can
at least make a cool time-lapse and see
how the park as a whole kind of comes
together so let's get started all right
now something to note here is that I am
NOT going to do anything ridiculous I
know that I have a pretty bad reputation
around these parts of doing weird things
and putting way too many objects into my
buildings but I was specifically told to
keep it not too crazy on the scenery in
this case especially also because the
performance in this park still had to be
good while at the same time being a
complete finished park surrounding so
the themes of this park are not going to
be too complicated and I'll try to keep
the amount with pieces as low as I can
also this was made in a very small
amount of time and I was kind of
stressing out so it might be a little
bit rushed at some parts and also in
general it's just well built to be build
as quickly as I could and you'll
probably see that come back a lot of the
ways that I built things are really just
because it's the fastest way to do
things now on into the buildings
themselves the first building that I
wanted to start out with is kind of the
most important building of at least this
part of the park basically what you're
looking at right now is the entrance
Plaza which is not too big it is not
going to be too large of a park
but I wanted to have some kind of big
eye catching building for the entrance
plaster not really a castle or something
really big but just one building that
kind of stands out from the rest and
gives it a sort of boom to it and that's
really why I figured I would go for a
somewhat larger building with a clock
tower just to give it that nice accent
and reason also why I did this and why
it's kind of to the side of the plaza
which is a bit unusual is that I had to
leave two empty spaces in the middle of
the park
for the peoples actually be able to
build on so it kind of had to be a
finished environment where you can just
build whatever you wanted to in the
middle in an unfinished empty cross plot
so I couldn't really fill up all of the
sides here and I didn't want to make a
centerpiece myself which is why it's
kind of a building that's a bit brush to
the side but yeah that's the first
building and the rest of the buildings
are more or less going to follow this
same sort of Alpine fantasy like theme
it doesn't really take the concepts and
pieces of the game and use them for
different reasons so I'll be just using
roofs as roofs walls as walls and
chimneys as actual chimneys in this case
and I won't go too crazy with combining
all of the different pieces to make new
things which means that I can get stuff
done a bit quicker and don't have to
worry as much about the performance but
it also means that the theme of this
really is going to be this standard kind
of Alpine fantasy theme which I'm quite
happy with but the reason why I usually
try to avoid it is just because it
doesn't use the pieces in the game in
two innovative ways which means that as
you sort of progress over time and more
people build more parks they all start
looking like each other so this is
probably not going to look like the most
unique parks and more like a sort of
general representation of what parks and
planet Costa can look like the second
house by the way is well really what the
rest of the houses are going to be like
and what the middle house is going to be
like as well just the simple gable roof
though in this case I did want to extend
it with that second part at the back of
just to give it a bit more body than
just being a simple facade for the side
of a Main Street also all of these
buildings will be just proper buildings
and not just the sides of a Main Street
so that's not really gonna happen anyway
but at least this back side of the
building adds a bit of depth to it
which I'm quite happy with what I'm also
really happy with actually and what is
one of the more defining features of the
otherwise pretty simple building is that
chimney on the side which is actually
made out of a bunch of different
chimneys or kind of stacked together
there isn't really a huge chimney that
you can have on the side of the building
in the game that could just come from
the bottom floor all the way up to the
roof so I figured I had to make it
myself I'm actually quite happy with how
it works out the chimneys do combine
pretty well into new kind of chimneys or
other objects if you so desire but um
the next building that I wanted to get
into is the final building which being
sort of the middle building of the Main
Street is more or less just filler and
kind of the unwanted filling middle
space in the main street that nobody
really cares about but you would kind of
see a gaping hole if there wasn't a
building there so this is not going to
be too interesting just well keeping
with the theme that I already have over
here taking a few new pieces but more or
less making sure that I kind of have a
filler that fits in with the buildings
that are already there and also it does
help to give all of these things a
function since I'm not going to have a
big Main Street or anything and I do
want to make sure that all of the basic
functions that you want to see in a park
actually present here so the big
building is the information building the
small building in the middle is the
cosmic cow which is not to cosmic Irish
there's not all of different billboards
and cosmic cow merchandise on the front
of the building it's a little bit subtle
I think it works out quite well and the
building on the right is the toilet
building I'm not sure why but I do
really feel like it's a toilet building
looking building not really sure what
would make it qualifies that but that's
just what I kind of feel about it anyway
I also wanted to make a quick
centerpiece for the plaza but I didn't
want to spend too much time on it
so I ended up doing is just put random
kind of decorations with flowers into
the ground I would usually want to blend
this out a bit more and not go with
random things but this is just a bit of
doodling and coming up with very quick
ways to arrange them on the spot this is
not the most realistic way to arrange
flowers but I'm still quite happy with
how it looks and the final thing that I
still have to do is getting some benches
and some lights and that finishes the
main plaza then I did a bit more work on
the path works and add some attractions
to the park and the next thing that I
wanted to do is add a very big
restaurant which is going to be the
biggest building of the park and really
the centerpiece restaurant kind of
function of the park and as such it's
going to be super wide and it's not
going to be too complicated since I
wanted to save quite a bit of time here
so as you can see a lot of this building
is just making small modular pieces that
you can copy around to make a really big
building very quickly so the roof is all
just made out of those pieces that can
be copied there are the wooden posts all
around it which was quite easy to make
as well and all of the walls and other
sides are also going to be copied around
since they are just going to be the same
piece and I don't have too many
different parts sticking out with
different styles and different ways of
making it throughout the entire building
just because this is a lot easier for me
obviously and because of that the
building does to announce I have a very
bland kind of standard shape to it just
not very long rectangular parts of the
main body and one roof that just sticks
out to make it look a bit more inviting
but it's still super standard and boring
so I wanted to add one touch to it to at
least give it a bit of character which
is the tower on the side don't decorate
it with anything else
don't add detract from the tower but
that's really the only thing that gives
the building a bit of a unique look and
something that's a bit more recognizable
than just a simple roof and some simple
walls and just for good measure I did
want to make sure that the details at
least
are good on this building since
especially if you have a building with
such a standard shape I always like to
add a bit more attention into the small
details and make sure that it's all as
clean as possible which does help make
the building look a bit more interesting
even though it is quite a simple
building now the one thing that does add
a bit of character to it is the tower
which I'm working on right here
still I didn't want to make it fairly
quickly so I just made one side of it
and copied that around and put a big
simple roof on it and pretty much played
it safe for the entire building not
doing anything crazy was playing around
a little bit with like some different
decorations for underneath the clock but
nothing really turned out to work that
well and I definitely wanted to keep
some parts of this clock tower is still
empty and the roof which is really the
most defining feature of the entire
building is also a slightly different
color with the green part sticking out
there to give it a bit more detail and
make it more interesting than than the
rest of the building and that is really
what I quite liked about it also one
thing to consider about this is that
even though it is a very simple building
right now and it looks like just one
very large rectangular boring facade I
will have some trees in front of it
which kind of book it out which doesn't
necessarily mean that the building is
going to be better but that's kind of
the idea then I wanted to make this
building with so you're going to be able
to see this building from the main
square and it's also sitting right next
to the two empty crawl spaces that are
supposed to be built in and as such it
should kind of come up behind the trees
as you've also seen at the beginning of
this video and mostly just get your
attention to the clock tower and leave
the rest of the building just be the
functional part of it
just very quickly also having the same
wall around the entire building which I
normally wouldn't want to do either want
to find some kind of way to at least
make the back of the building look a bit
more back stage and like it's actually a
functional back side where you could
load things into building and such
things but in this case I had to be
quite quick about it so it's just
simple backside which is practically the
same as the front except without the
roof that sticks out then I did a bunch
more work on some different flat rides
and scenery around the park which you
can also kind of see as I move around
there and there's even a bit of foliage
but the next thing that I wanted to do
which was the interesting thing that I
still need to show is make a coaster and
this went super easy actually I do have
to say this is one of the first courses
that I made in alpha 3 the only courses
that I've made so far are a couple very
small test coasters kind of but I
haven't actually made a serious coaster
so far except for the flying coaster in
phantasy Valley and this was kind of my
first play with how it would work and I
do have to say as a personal critique I
do think that friction on the track is
way too bad I'm still quite happy with
how this layout turned out I didn't
actually test it I was just hoping that
my too many years of experience in these
kinds of games would make sure that this
layout would run through the entire
thing and still have some good speed on
the airtime Hills but even still it was
a bit slower than I expected and I
definitely have to say that the friction
right now in the game just seems too low
to be realistic but still playing with
that I just met this layouts to seem
like a realistic VN I'm hiper I'm not
actually sure if it's technically a
hyper it doesn't look like it really
breaks to 200 feet but it's it's the
hyper kind of coaster in any case it's
also an older version since I wanted to
have a pre drop on its nose well no
particular reason why I wanted to have a
pre drop it just kind of seemed like
something that would look good on the
coaster so I went with it and it's just
the kind of coaster that I wanted to add
to get a skyline in the background that
would put the rest of the park into a
more theme park like mood it's not
really the most imaginative coaster and
pretty much just came up with the layout
as I was going around it so it isn't
really anything particularly you
League or creative but it's something
that just helps get a larger kind of
thrilling ride in the background and you
can see it from practically every part
of the park just makes the rest of the
park look like it's more of a part of a
theme park which is why I wanted to add
a hyper coaster in the first place
and quickly finishing that up also
here's how I did much of the foliage
just saving a bunch of trees in a
blueprint which isn't always the most
performance great idea because you might
have a few trees that overlap and some
bushes underneath it that aren't exactly
necessary but in this case it saved a
lot of time and I definitely recommend
it if you do want to be very quick about
it
though in general I do want to mix up
foliage in different points of park so
I'm not usually a big fan of copying
foliage around but if you want to get
things done quickly it's a great way to
do so and the rest of the foliage is
just very simple a bunch of decorative
trees in some different arrangements to
make everything look a bit more fancy
but there's no rocket science going on
there also there were just some parts of
the park that I couldn't finish at least
not really in a very interesting way so
that I in the end just ended up filling
with more foliage in this case I felt
like it maybe would have been cool to
have a flat right behind the big
restaurant building over here and make
that area next to the coaster a little
bit more interesting but there wasn't
really any time for it and I wanted to
focus on some different things instead
so decided to in the end just put a
quick toilet building in here and let
the foliage do the rest of the filling
up work the toilet building is quite
interesting though just very quick
building to kind of fit in with the
theme but still look like it's a small
toilet stall instead of really a themed
building
a little bit inspired by the roller
coaster tycoon one toilet buildings if
that's not a too stupid thing to say but
there's not too much inspiration going
on there it's just a similar kind of
toilet building I do still love that
thing a lot and have a quick head run at
the back of it to kind of separate it
from that forest behind it and also make
sure that you can't really go there
because that's just backstage and
unfinished area and you don't want
people to see the unfinished area moving
on though the next thing that I wanted
to do is get a pirate ship in which is
just a thing that I wanted to do because
it looks very fancy and it's always nice
to have one of these things beside the
lake it's a very picturesque kind of
thing and it's really one of those safe
ways to do certain things if you want to
have a flat ride that looks cool just
make a pirate ship put it next to a lake
have a bunch of rocks and foliage maybe
a building next to it and it's bound to
look good so that's what I'm going for
here and I had this cue a thing already
copied from two other rights that I made
earlier so there is a lot of copying
things to save time here but I did want
to add a specific touch to it every time
and in this case I wanted to add a tower
next to the pirate ship which turned out
to be a bit more annoying than I figured
beforehand since the pirate ship is
something that I completely forgot about
here and it is almost going to hit the
tower so I had to do a bit of building
gymnastics to make sure that the tower
would just stay lower than the pirate
ship when it swings but it's right about
in the safe zone so I'm quite happy with
how the tower works out on the side
there and just to get rid of that very
mechanical looking orange color of the
base of the ride I wanted to have a
bunch of rock work underneath it and
I'll put some foliage in there as well
to spruce it up a bit and make it look a
bit more finished but this is like one
of the last big things that I still did
in the park now almost at the end some
of the finishing touches is and in
details and over here you can already
kind of see what the park is looking
like in it's almost finished stage
these are really the final touches of
foliage and scenery around all of all of
the parts that I have and this is more
or less what it turned into I want to
end this video with a couple of
cinematic shots to just give you another
idea of what the park looks like in the
end and yeah that is just about it for
today thank you guys so much for
watching and I hope to see you guys next
time in which hopefully I'll be back to
fantasy valley or some kind of other
projects see you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you